walk me through step by step your sex
with Justin Bieber oh my God are you a
morning sex or night sex people
more so night Haley Bieber opening up
and getting down with her hubby Justin
[Music]
and she's hoping her parents will cover
their ears for this one my parents are
gonna listen to this there's something
that feels so cringe no about your
parents the model gets very candid with
host Alex Cooper on spotify's call her
daddy podcast about sexy time with JB
and let's just say she's sharing a lot
of sensual secrets okay so your night
sex people we love that okay this is so
graphic but I'm saying the words okay
for the rest of your life you have to
pick one of the two okay from Mr Bieber
are you going to be
or for the rest of your life you can
only take one
because I feel like it's always a
combination yeah like I said
sensual Secrets people so I'm like yeah
that's me do you and Justin have the
same favorite positions
I think so
it's not like I'm like I strictly like
this one thing and he strictly likes
another thing can you give us like one
or two
or five
it's always different okay yeah it's
always something different do you want
to give us one and it can't be
missionary it's definitely not
missionary I
really like doggy style but Haley's also
got boundaries specifically when it
comes to the idea of a threesome or an
open relationship would you be down
no it's funny because
I feel like
those ideas can be really fun and like
sound really exciting I think at the at
the point that of inside of our it
doesn't work for the two of us we worked
very hard to like be in the space that
we're in now and like
trusting each other and there's like
such a beautiful trust and bond that I
just don't think that's something I
would be comfortable with
or him for that matter so Hales has got
her turn offs but what about her biggest
turn on it can be like a connection
thing it can be a physical thing for me
kissing is a big deal
like that's a that's a big thing for me
it always has been just like in my life
before I was married so I would say that
is probably the most we have a good time
together
it's really sweet he's a good kid he's a
good part and uh I love him sex stuff
aside Haley also opens up about the
struggles that come with being in a
relationship with someone as famous as
Justin including the online hate she
says she gets on a daily basis
I think it's sad to be against someone's
happiness I think it's sad to not wish
somebody well who am I supposed to be
that would be acceptable and then that
means that I'm living for other people
and that means that I'm being a people
pleaser which I struggle with a lot I do
want people to like me but despite all
the struggles the two-faced Haley says
she and Justin are working through it
all together he's my best friend I love
coming home to him but like yeah it
takes work because I'm 25 years old and
I have a life and I have a career and I
have my own friends so trying to balance
making my
wants and needs and hopes and dreams
work well meshing my life with another
human who has his hopes and dreams and
career and like we're busy people and we
want to be in a marriage so we're making
it work and sometimes it's hard
[Music]